your cast for Pink Zone very young
attractive cast what made you choose
that cast I chose that cast because I
wanted to have people who were fresh and
new and could experiment with their
characters with improvisation because I
relied a lot on improvisation and
without no judgment on their characters
and that's what I love about them that
they had no preconceived ideas about
their own characters and each single day
when they came on set I was being able
to direct them in a way they could take
from their own life too and build the
characters in a much closer way to them
your approach working with an actress
versus an actor I know with actresses
I'm a woman we're concerned with the way
we look so they take a little longer
sometimes to get ready and they're more
concerned with certain things so your
approach with an actress versus an actor
I you know as I have to say I worked
with them both with no different
approach at all for me they were their
characters I had a different approach
for each actor because a lot of the
actress worked in a different way and so
I'm tuning my my approach as a director
to each actor rather than male and girls
and so and so now all the girls were so
committed they didn't lose any time just
like this myth of a hair and makeup
everybody was just so committed and
there was no time for there was
literally no time for small things like
that
you